[Musique]
des eagles à mozart en passant par queen
ou alain souchon un répertoire varié
pour un voyage dans le temps
les 50 choristes des trous bader vous
emmènent dans leur vaisseau temporelle
des troncs baader sont l'équipage et
accueille le public comme des passagers
et l'idée c'est d'aller répondre à deux
questions fondamentales de l'humanitaire
qui de la poule ou de l'oeuf est arrivé
le premier
et puis une deuxième question quand les
poules auront elles des temps ce qu'on
veut faire cf s'est amusé le public
s'est partagé avec lui tout le plaisir
qu'on a monté le spectacle on part sur
l'humour
pour les jeux
dans la conversation
et l opinion
du rire et de la légèreté mais surtout
du théâtre du chant et de la musique
l'association créée en 2003 a écrit
elle-même 110e spectacle chaque membre
un rôle bien particulier
je suis dans les costumes je suis dans
le théâtre et mon rôle dans le spectacle
c'est capitaine du vaisseau
c'est lui qui va prendre les décisions
face aux difficultés du voyage donc lui
doit rester sérieux hélas pour moi
embarquement prévu les 9 et 10 juin à
chevreuse et si certains se sentent
l'âme créative la troupe cherche
toujours de nouveaux venus pour l'année
prochaine
[Musique]